let's bring in now Joe Maddon e angels
manager joins us on the program how
bored are you Joe it's not I'm not bored
actually it's difficult to boy we have
we're out here in Mesa Arizona Jay and I
in our RV hunkered down near Apache
Junction I get threatened my bike every
day I get to cook every day so I've been
working out reading I got some other
ideas we had a tremendous conference
call yesterday among all the angel staff
so everything exactly been non boring
how do you stay in touch with your
players well that's that's next here's
what we got going on as Tim buses vice
president of stuff now he used to be the
Quality Assurance coach we established
him as the vice president of stuff wait
wait it says title vice president of
stuff so he's gonna get together a phone
list or an email list slash text list
that I could get in touch with the
players with that talk to Albert I've
talked I haven't talked to Mike but I've
talked to Albert recently and I want to
get back into these guys how to get back
home settled in and get their routines
their routines down to what they're
doing right now so that's that's worth
coming and it's difficult being a first
year manager with this team because
you're still trying to assess what you
have do you do you have a good idea from
what you saw in training camp I do I
think I do um you know coming into camp
of course talked a lot with Billy
epilator and a lot of the other front
office folks but then I got to see them
on the field for a couple three weeks
whatever it was and I felt good about
what I what I saw I actually felt really
good about what I saw I thought there's
a lot more talent there than was being
given credit for I mean we have some
really nice young players I I was uh I
mean really across with a lot of the
arms pitching wise so it was better than
I thought actually it's really good and
yesterday the phone call when I was able
to participate with some internal
knowledge but I haven't seen these guys
so I feel pretty good about it have you
been tested for the coronavirus I'm not
I'm not a we've been just sitting like I
said out here
in RV we've kept in contact with
constantly by our trainer Adam Neville
Adam Texas the other day we have to
answer this questionnaire and to this
point I don't think I've not been told
to do that nothing given that
opportunity but right now we're just
hanging out any idea when you play
baseball this year I don't you know I'm
I guess you know me a little bit now I'm
pretty optimistic about things and you
know a perfect world I like to believe
well at least be able to get together in
the middle of May in a perfect world if
that weather goes in that direction I
think if we follow all the restrictions
in place and I think that's the biggest
thing right now I'm the more I read
about it the more I understand we all
understand it obviously hunkering down
is the right thing to do the biggest
part of that I think is that we get the
message out to younger folks I think
that's the part had I been in my 20s mid
20s I'd probably be difficult for me to
wrap my mind around all of this - I
think thought I read dr. Adams made a
really good point about getting some of
the younger iconic members that are
really active on social media to get to
their audiences and I thought that was
wise I've been thinking about that
driving around ask about my bike so that
would be a good thing to do to get
everybody understand that the more we
stay in one place the sooner this goes
away and also you have you know Kevin
Durant tested positive you got Tom Hanks
who tested positive people probably feel
or felt well where I live it's not going
to happen to me or it's like we don't
know who's carrying it but now when you
have name recognition there and then two
members of the Lakers we don't know
their names yet but it's coming you know
and you know there might not be anything
we can do to prevent it right but
they're the one thing we can do to
squash it a little bit sooner would be
like just like it's been suggested I'm
you might not follow the the edicts that
they helped officials right now I don't
know enough none of us know enough so I
got to follow their lead right now and
and I think you know there's probably a
demographic a certain age group that's
more readily accepting of all these
measures even though you don't like not
going out or you don't like the fact you
can't go to a bar restaurant you still
do it
but there's also the group that does
more bulletproof when you're your teens
into your twenties you
bulletproof so we need to get the I
think that's that would be appropriate
to get the messaging out to their more
than consistently an accepted I'm gonna
start doing in the next couple days I
really I have I'm active social media
wise idea Twitter but I think it's
important that I get out there even more
often right now so I got some things in
the works with the Angels and discuss
things with MLB to try to get me and not
just me more of the players coaches etc
involved on a daily basis to reach out
to Japan's and the general public and be
more both entertaining and implemented
Joe good to talk to you and it sounds
like you're keeping active there and we
appreciate your time did you take care
no that's Joe Madden angels manager